[Music]
hey Conan O'Brien here with a vintage
edition of clueless gamer and I'm here
with my pal
Aaron Blair hello we've pretty much
played many of the cutting-edge modern
games absolutely
and I'm routinely I'm terrible that's
rude and contemptuous of the medium and
we are going to look at some of the
classic Atari video games is that right
that's right we're doing kind of a
throwback episode we're gonna see how it
all started the Atari 2600 is kind of
the grandfather of all video games I
thought this was a a grill a George
Foreman grill I'm glad you told me that
was just about to put the shoe hamburger
patties back and start grilling now
quickly show me the video game
controllers that we've been using all
the games I've reviewed pretty much yes
have been with this incredibly
sophisticated control system but let's
step back in time look at this yeah this
looks like the defibrillator they used
on Elvis we're gonna play a lot of games
today but the game that came with the
Atari 2600 was called combat it came
with a booklet this smells like the mid
70s
it smells like Stevie Nicks shove it in
there okay and then flip on the power
alright so you're just gonna try to kill
me you're the ones my I'm the blue tank
yep
I can barely tell that's a tank it looks
vaguely sexual people played this for
the first time they thought this is the
most amazing thing that ever happened
yes exactly this is their minds were
blown there's nothing here that's
remotely tank-like alright I now know
why everyone was high back then the only
way to make these games exciting this is
dreadful let's put it on watch paint dry
alright now we're gonna look at Missile
Command another Atari game that promises
much more than it can deliver the cover
art aliens from the planet of Cristal
have begun an attack on the planet Czar
Don the proto Lian's had begun fight
someone had to write this and you know
what we know we're about to see three
blimps they prepared me for oh there we
go yeah those are Tony ins and cryto
Lian's alright what do I do
so you move the dash around yeah so the
colored circles knock out the blips ok
now while you're explaining to me my
I've lost my city do you know what this
city looks like [ __ ]
at the time what's really scary is this
was about the sophistication of the
computer that controlled our nuclear
missiles
the Russians probably saw these games
and thought we should attack now these
are dreadful
absolutely dreadful but we're moving on
to golf there's a nice depiction on the
front of what I think is Senator Robert
Kennedy and then we're gonna see how its
depicted here already in this game oh
god what's happening now is that a human
being
I hope he's holding
girl season earth lady's movements so
fluid so golf life what a horrible era
for mankind I can go and look at an old
butter churn or a turn-of-the-century
bar tone I can appreciate the beauty of
it absolutely I can look at a 1950s
bakelite phone and it still works and
it's very beautiful this is awful this
is just America on its knees here we go
River raid of a raid there we go
plane on the plane and I was going over
a river when I drift to the side I
shouldn't be smashing into the bank of
the river right right so I don't
understand where I am in time and space
I may in the air who's this remember a
river a river where a this may be the
worst day of my life so this is actually
one of the most popular games that Atari
had it's called pitfall pitfall look
this is the genius behind this game
right here they can struggle before he
snapped I murdered everyone in his condo
all right so here we go that's me
yep nothing that's a log you supposed to
jump oh that's bad going this way okay
did you want a jump on that
I don't even know what I'm doing that's
the one direction in the whole game is
that does that supposed to help us
what's that we the space invaders we're
space invaders this game oh right I just
dodged what they're doing and fire is
that right that's it you know what this
is actually an OK game though still
there we go this is a game
aim and I'm actually playing it and I
know what I'm doing we found my game
space invaders yes awesome holds up so
we had a poll online yeah where fans
could choose what game they wanted to
see you play okay they chose this et the
extra-terrestrial now here's the thing
about ET it's widely regarded as the
worst video game of all time worse than
the Gulf it's really
[Music]
yeah okay see BT is coming down in an
elevator yes the elevators just left him
in a swamp where am I going I'm just
he's just pacing nervously and who's
that guy I think he's the FBI agent
don't let him touch you if you see a man
in a trench coat and never let him talk
to you that is a piece of your telephone
the whole point of this game is to
collect three pieces of your telephone
then call your spaceship and it comes
back to rescue you
okay now go up now you're flying yeah so
I got my piece of my telephone yeah well
that's a flower so you hit the thing and
the flower will go up why would I make
flower go that's the point of that thing
it was in the movie I don't think I
remember are you filling another hole
you just got to do the next thing and
get out so there's a lot of just falling
in a hole and then extending my neck and
that's basically the whole game this
just simulates the cycles of depression
the sound effects are fantastic listen
this is the one the fans wanted me to
play yeah thank you fans having the
experience that the fans asked me to
play et the extra-terrestrial let me
write it if flock of seagulls is good
and Duran Duran is bad I'm gonna give
this Amen at work I did like space
invaders it was a fun game for me to
play it took me back to a time when I
was about to lose my virginity it was a
thrilling experience for me yeah
this means a lot to me let's never do
this again
[Applause]
[Music]